you warm me up I say you're a nice guy I
really felt we're about to be friends
and now I'm Bassam Jane cutter of my
hatred for Sean Evans oh hey what's
going on everybody for first week feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings and today we're
joined by Ken Jong you know him from
massively popular films like The
Hangover and crazy rich Asians as many
hit TV shows and even the stand-up stage
speaking of his first ever comedy
special acepted Netflix this month ken
Jeong welcome to the show the air is
already too spicy
oh I know that you're a licensed medical
doctor out of curiosity have you done
anything special to prepare for a
recover from today's meal um
I cried this morning I had three silent
panic attacks oh my kids wouldn't hear
me but I don't want to be here and I am
scared of you not you as a person right
rate talk before you sound amazing and
lovely and nice but scared of this
scared the brand and I'm scared at least
three of these
[Music]
handle sorry - the handle mm-hmm
[ __ ] yeah okay all right okay
I saw no Michael B Jordan went where he
to see Jesus get much occasion you
okay don't play Sean Evans one plane so
comedy is rife with intense origin
stories but it's hard for me to think of
anything more grueling than attending
the UNC Chapel Hill School of Medicine
while also doing open mic sets are the
things that you find funny about being a
doctor now different than the bits that
you're doing in medical school that's a
great question I think the bits I was
doing in medical I really did I really
did any medical bits during medical
school because I thought it was I was
really too soon so I really really just
I just did a lot of dancing I just
danced and played some guitar like
nothing was too hacky for me you know I
wasn't doing any carlin desk writing it
was just more therapy just to be on just
to kind of it was a great outlet was my
golf I remember thinking that the whole
time
I like the caution that you take with
each wing you know I'm a [ __ ] doctor
dude you gotta be careful with this
stuff so your careers check so many
boxes from breakout roles and
blockbuster films to cameos and Enrique
Iglesias music video so here we'll dive
into some of the finer notes of your
acting resume what was the best and
worst thing about sharing a trailer with
Donald Glover during your time on
community that's the best question ever
the best the best thing he'd be working
on his early childhood Gambino albums
I've got to hear just through the walls
like early tracks of freaks and geeks
whenever he wasn't working he was
writing and and I really respected that
and and that inspires me to this day
like if I was on crazy rich Asians or to
do it something you know I was actually
working on a script myself so that was
directly inspired by you know by what I
saw Donald - for five years on community
but having said that the music got kind
of loud and I think I became grumpy old
man
who's funnier behind the scenes Zach
Galifianakis or Shaq well Shaq he's a
legend but in terms of pure comedy Zach
Galifianakis is he's probably the
funniest person I've ever worked with
period what's the movie quote that fans
yell at you most of the wild um a lot of
it's there you know toot-a-loo
[ __ ] - I get that a lot
I do remember um maybe it's because
we're having food here I do remember
early on right after the right after the
first hangover where without a food
court with my wife and kids and my
daughter was 2 years old at the time
Zoey and someone was yelling out from
the mall was just like hey you're gonna
[ __ ] on me and then um
Lilly my daughter my daughter without
not knowing it's about without missing a
beat he goes no he won't [ __ ] on you I'm
like Zoey let's just come on
just eat your waffle fries all right
just let's just take a beat like this is
more hot chest and not one time looking
at your move
all right patios potion what's harder to
deal with as a performer getting
savagely heckled on stage or seeing
someone have a medical emergency in the
audience I did a show in last year where
so no third-row had a seizure and it was
um it was a it was a petit mal seizure
thank God it was just very very mild
relative you know to that condition but
um I the whole crowd just stopped and I
dropped the mic women to doctor mode and
jumped off stage to try to help out the
person and you know just still I still
think about her all the time and I
actually flew her out too and her
boyfriend out to New York to one of my
shows the following week and just
treated her and a boyfriend out to like
a whole week in New York to enjoy the
size and paid for their hotel room and
flight and everything and done it never
came to a [ __ ] show that stand-ups
are as good at anyone as complaining do
you ever find that comedians share their
ailments with you backstage every single
[ __ ] time every time I've ever done
stand-up movies TV I remember this was
like 18 years ago I was at the Laugh
Factory in Hollywood and I had a set but
I did very well I you know I really
Guittard it up that night in this
national headliner comedy legend I was
like hey come here I was like oh my god
maybe maybe it'll take me on the road
with him I could be his opening act so I
went to the bathroom with him he
literally lifted up his shirt hey Doc do
you think do you think this is skin
cancer or do you think is just a mold is
there anything and uh I was like you
know it's it's just a moment
did you see the set nope you know then
walked away which comedian do you think
would make the worst patient oh god
there's so many I am putting myself to
where we are all broken toys and we're
all neurotic so I would have to say all
comedians make the worst patients
I would never want to be a comedian
doctor
[Music]
feeble gone it's a great name so far I
think the best name I just I just feel
like these are these are like land mines
of like it's almost like designed -
speaking of neurotic we had a Halloween
police so it's not every day that we
have a doctor in the hot seat so what I
want to do is hit you with some popular
internet folk wisdom and you can just
tell me if it checks out with your
medical training okay okay you can get
the flu by getting a flu shot nope nope
it's a recombinant artificial vaccine
it's not a live attenuated vaccine so
that is the biggest myth sugar is just
as addictive as heroin sugar is
addictive junk food is addictive but I
would hasten to say that heroin is is by
far the most addictive we only use 10%
of our brains well you know yeah to you
but it's um I don't know if this is a
cheap of gold talking but I I think that
number does sound right 10 to 15% that
does sound right I don't know the exact
percentage but that's that's as the
spectrum of truth blue balls are very
serious medical condition very real it
is not a very serious medical condition
you know sorry fellas
spicy food gives you all sirs yes
absolutely you know which is why I'm
[ __ ] worried right now breaking the
seal makes you have to pee more [ __ ] no
that's like you don't want it you could
you could get into I mean if they're
they're horrible cases of urinary
retention that could lead to kidney
failure if you could hold it in and and
like it you have the kidneys and then
your your doors go down to the bladder
and then if you if it gets so congested
it could it could actually reflux back
into the kidney and and blow out your
kidney so break the seal everybody
you'll break that seal dog break it
[Music]
doing better than you thought you would
so far actually I am yeah I'm doing
better than I thought I really thought
that you know because I watch a show and
I am I am a legit fan but I've seen
people I've seen friends of mine buckle
and it's painful to watch
and um it's painful to see my friends
suffer and but brave of you to take it
on gun yeah
all right can we have recurrent segments
on our show called explain that Graham
where do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram put interesting pictures that
need more context and today we have a
theme it's an all sports edition of
explained that Graham so I'll bust out
the laptop I'll show you the picture and
you tell me the bigger story does that
sound good
nope what's going on here uh-huh
here you are Kevin Durant yeah that was
at a tiki party that I crashed I do
remember going a little bit on and on
about like I was a little bit too nerdy
about how how amazing a shooter he was
like he got really into the weed I got
really into the wheeze and he was
completely bored you know five-minute
three like I mean Reggie Miller is
amazing but you have the athleticism and
that you could go post and go so many
ways and no one has had the combination
of like your athletic skills and your
basketball IQ and you just complete
packs and literally like while I was
saying that he was just like looking
around to see if there's like you know
more just more entertaining to people to
talk to
I just remember yeah man see you later
dark and it like just walked away and my
wife was it was there how did it go I
was like it was great we're like best
friends you know he's just like you know
I just repeated what I said to him you
know when she started skating and then
she started skiing around and then
oh yes your day with the Dodgers there
is a story behind that um I was there
for game 7 and I was carrying the flag
and Carlos Correa in it I think Sports
Illustrated has a photo he shoves a cup
of ice water in my face
unprovoked you know while I'm doing it
boom boom savage savage savage AF and
I'm Whittle I think Rob Lowe is on the
other side I'm on there and like we're
just caring like and you know they won't
I guess it won't shove water and Rob
Lowe cuz he's Rob Lowe you know he's Rob
Lowe but they'll do it at Chow any time
so I was trying to be respectful but
Carlos credited Sheldon and it totally
startled me I was still wiping off all
the water off of my Dodger Jersey and my
jeans and my face and by the time I got
to my seat but uh the Astros had already
scored like three runs that works Mindy
remember like in Game seven
they had a quick lead and I'm like wow
Carlos come on can't we be friends
brutal you want a mild hot wing Carlos
hit that one I know that you're a sports
an obsessive
rest in peace Stuart Scott I'm a North
Carolina native Stuart Scott also North
Carolina I just guess co-anchored
SportsCenter I think a few months prior
and he came up to me out of the blue
both he and Scott Van Pelt and said hey
you know I respect you because you
really I tried hard like I I actually
went to the pre-production meeting I was
trying to pitch out like NBA storylines
you know and and I and I was writing my
own copy
you know like in each I was really
trying to try to do it and it's a first
Stuart Scott to say seen a lot of
celebrities come here and you're the
only one that really respected what we
do to this day I'll never forget that
and we just kept in touch ever since and
just a shout out to everybody in the
Scott family Stuart Scott is just he
really is a pioneer for sports
journalism so um so
much love
a double logo
I'll [ __ ] you know I could see that
coming
stop thinking about everything you relax
me and then you a Adobe look of me could
probably go for that ice water bath
right now I could probably go you know
so I know that in addition to being an
actor and a comedian you're a loving
father of your girls seen The Hangover
yet
no they have not they're 11 and and I am
I am I am nervous as to you know that
eventual day I'm nervous about that
eventual day I mean that's that's more
stressful to me than the birds and bees
talks you know no mana seduces all right
all right all right what's the most
honest feedback they've ever given to
you about a TV or movie role do you ever
find that they can deliver a harsh truth
on your team can't I was doing them I
was doing a set of a music video for a
friend of a family friend of ours Laura
Morana
she'd starve off finale and then the
Mirana family they're good family
friends of ours so they featured so in
the video and me and so I wanted to it
was a nice fun and they wanted to do a
nice father-daughter video and we were
doing all these over-the-top takes me
and Laura and her mother Ellen were just
crying you know like having a fun time
just improvising and putting and and
literally Zoe was on her iPad like
completely unimpressed and just looked
at me and she said are we done are we
done
[Music]
I got a nut up do this torch bared
garlic Reaper what's wrong with you
careful around your eyes nope
right right no I'm looking for you Thank
You Sean thank you thank you for being
kind of an ally
let me add that to uh yeah yeah now it's
getting late
this is getting my fourth quarter pepper
right now I see you know starts out a
friendly exhibition game technically
third quarter still shut up shut the
[ __ ] up Sean so you have the rare
distinction of having degrees from both
North Carolina and Duke but you make no
secret about where your allegiance lies
what's the most classless thing you
either participated in or witnessed as a
member of the Cameron Crazies two things
offend me
you know you and also saying that
anything the Cameron Crazies did was
offensive
we're satirical and we one of my
favorite a guy from Clemson was
inbounding the ball Clemson versus Duke
at Cameron the guys name was howling
none of us knew who the Clemson players
were there weren't our enemy we didn't
hate them at all they just started
howling they just Karla I just remember
like 50 guys going and I was just crying
laughing while their inbounding the ball
every time you touch the ball they would
just start so nothing not no MBA game is
ever competed with me coming back to
home do you remember your first
impression of Coach K when you did a
Sirius XM show back in 2013 dude
although I hate you I respect you thank
you for knowing that I just stood there
and I just did not speak unless spoken
to I was a willing Wallflower even if it
was right here I wouldn't even try to
make icon you know like you know it's
like I wanted to be that respectful and
he came up to me and talked to me and
he's just so chill and then while we're
on the topic of college I think some of
your more casual fans might be surprised
to learn that you directed an excellent
ESPN 30 for 30 documentary about Notre
Dame footballs Reggie ho what can you
tell the people about his story and why
were you drawn
to it well you know all credit goes to
ESPN for that because they reached out
to me and they they asked for me to
direct this um
thirty four thirty short film about
Reggie ho who is their star kicker and
Notre Dame in 1988 who he was a walk-on
his whole goal was just to be a doctor
but he was a kicker in high school and
he tried out unsuccessfully for the
first two years and then he tried out
the third year I believe got in and he
scored for winning field goals against
Michigan that one that Michigan game
early on in the season that momentum of
that game propelled them to win the
national championship and Reggie ho is a
national hero and he became a
cardiologist and thank you for for
shouting that out because it's one of my
favorite things I've ever done it's a
cool story yeah and I and I it's not
like and I wasn't in it you know wasn't
like jumping out of a field naked hey
you know wasn't like that vanity project
I was very respectful to to Reggie in
his life and it was really just a labor
of love so thank you
all right I'm beginning to beginning to
like you yeah well yeah well hold on to
that thought
[Music]
[ __ ] you Shani
[Music]
sit the nice you said student-athlete
you bring up the youth Meehan you warm
me up I say you're a nice guy I really
felt we're about to be friends and now
I'm back and change cutter of my hatred
for Sean Evans and
[Music]
as that time whoa says we've touched
down a little bit today you're a huge
MBA super I've seen you giving out
alternative awards on ESPN like best
free-throw shimmy sure the best hair
line yeah but let's focus on the current
crop yeah
which NBA player do you think would be
the most fun to do karaoke with um
[Music]
ah Shack
who do you think would have the best
chance at making it as a comedian that
was a leap dog that was a leap between
[Music]
Wow
you're a good respect the enemy best
villain
aha
lambier bill laimbeer there's no way
really doing a number on that picture
can why do you think everyone should
study the teachings of legendary Bulls
coach Phil Jackson because of his Maori
jobs and Christianity's and the art of
basketball and the fact that there five
people to a team let you work in concert
like five fingers to a hand most notably
the important one is the middle one that
was incidentally I'm looking at my wife
it is that hot this is no joke
trying to let out the bomb and Wow
you can sell Cod you don't have to go
Glad look in your eyes dude i i feel
empathy i can't help it
but I can see that you're strong
so with that I feel some comfort
okay so you've carried a passion for
music throughout your career from
acoustic sets about the history of hip
hop ins you know to most recently
judging the singing chops of costume
celebrities on the masked singer yes you
know thank you for asking
I heard that the first real concert that
you ever went to was Prince yeah Purple
Rain tour I love that album so much I
listened to it so many times when I came
out I bought it on a cassette tape and I
remember him playing Darlie Nikki and I
remember he was stroking the the neck of
the guitar and then now it just came out
like fluid and I was like what the [ __ ]
and then everything was perfectly
choreographed sinked I mean it was the
perfect show still the best concert I've
ever been to a real showman that prints
alright Ken a lovely [ __ ]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last
meeting [ __ ] you don't have to if you
don't want to okay you don't have to if
you don't want to
[Music]
I'm afraid I'm gonna have to go to a
burn unit if I use my pinkies are like a
make it there it comes
okay that's good that's good
yeah all right what a journey it's been
my mission
bottoms up arms up buddy
time's up
[Music]
all right gun here we are there giant
leap I know and here we are at the end
of the line and people are always
telling me Shawn you need to see a
doctor
eating spicy chicken wings weekend and
wing out it cannot be good for you and
even though I recently received a clean
bill of health I think that it's only
fair that we show the people the people
they're never satisfied
so we'll lean on your medical background
here let's see if you can do a basic
physical with the trillion scovilles
running through you nurse bring out my
stethoscope actually your stethoscope
where'd you go like right hand school
come on put my left hand ahead dog
oh yeah okay I think well I mean we just
do a little bit of doctoring here Oh
guys listen to your stomach turning your
bowel sounds
you actually got a decent about so if we
good a good on you well if you hear from
dr. Ken then you know it's the truth
here I am soldiering on and look at you
can ten chicken wings up ten chicken
wings down and even a full picture of
ice water now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life in general in
general okay
[Music]
yes I my my Netflix special is it's
coming out my first stand-up hour
special ever so it's one of the most fun
things I've ever done and I hope
everyone enjoys it you know it's just
kind of rekindled my love affair with
stand-up and I'm still doing it to this
day and all my material will be about
you good job I love this man I got legit
skating hey what's going on everybody
this is Sean Evans checking in to say
thank you so much what's up spice Lords
camera guy bill here I just couldn't get
enough of this glitz and glamour so I
came back to tell you if you want to buy
some official hot ones merchandise go to
shop first we feast calm if you're lazy
you can just click one of these t-shirts
down there this is camera guy bill here
saying it's good to be camera guy bill
[Music]